[Music]
hey you guys
happy whatever day today it's just day
days
it's tuesday
i think it's tuesday
we saw a real good movie last night this
was a [ __ ] classic i saw i've only
seen this one like two or three times
and i haven't seen it in a long long
time
it's called three days of the condor now
i remembered it as five days of the
condor and it's based on a book
called five days yeah six days in the
condor that's right i remembered it as
six days the condor and that's the name
of the book but this is called three
days of the condor
it's the same story they shortened the
time you shortened the timeline well i
think actually they changed quite a lot
from the book at least i haven't read
the book but i just wrote a quick
synopsis of it and they did kind of
change themselves a lot they changed the
location they changed like a bunch of
other stuff badass robert redford flick
from the 70s dino de laurentiis film all
right got a lot of good things about it
and it's basically a james bond type
movie spy movie but uh realistic kind of
like casino royale in a certain way but
even more realistic than that there's no
real like uh unbelievable action scenes
with [ __ ] cars or [ __ ] flying off
bridges and you know dangling by none of
that [ __ ]
it's just kind of a realistic
spy movie and it's about this dude
who works for just something called the
company
it's something we have to do with the
cia because they show the central
intelligence agency
and he's an agent but he's not a field
agent played by robert redford
he works in new york and works at this
office and it just looks like a normal
office nobody knows what this is but
it's a secret
cia installation well the front is it's
the american historical literary society
that's what they call what the front is
but what his job is is just to read
books
and spy books and [ __ ] like that and
come up with [ __ ] badass ideas
and enter him into a computer so see how
he can use those ideas out of the blue
one day
he goes out to lunch and while he's out
to lunch some dudes come in there with
[ __ ] suppressed mac teds
and [ __ ] shoot the place up and kill
his whole [ __ ] all his friends his
girlfriend his chinese girlfriend and
everything comes back and they're all
shot up
and he's uh
and then and then he realizes that
he tries to call back to the company
tells him what happened and they're
telling him to report back in but he
gets real suspicious about it and he
goes he goes on the run
and they go after him and he uses all
his [ __ ] knowledge
to try to survive and figure out
what the [ __ ] is happening who's after
him and why and uh and he's trying to
survive and he's not a field agent he's
just a he's he's a he's just a book worm
he's a
he's a brain bug that's what he is he's
a brain bug that would be on starship
troopers and uh it's a good flick real
good kind of reminds me a little bit of
of uh
of the marathon man in a way that's
another good flick we're gonna do that
one too
but uh if you like james bond movies you
need to see this one this is good
yeah for whatever reason when we were
talking about the believers yesterday
uh well we brought up marathon man
because that was done by the same uh
director
and so we're like oh yeah we should see
and then you brought up three days of
the condor so then like last night when
we were thinking about a movie i said
well do you want to do marathon man or
three days of the condor or whatever and
so we started watching that it was like
amazon prime yeah actually three bucks i
had forgotten that this movie i saw this
movie a long time ago probably when i
was uh on cable when i was a teenager
and i remembered liking it but i didn't
remember a lot about it i had forgotten
that cindy [ __ ] sydney pollock
directed this uh he was the same
director he's an actor as well uh he's
the same director that did jeremiah
johnson uh there you go one of your
favorite favorite uh he did tootsie
absence of malice out of africa
and uh he he's been in a [ __ ] ton of
movies like as an actor you probably
reckon he was actually in
eyes wide shut he played the uh the
doctor
yeah well you know the the doctor that
they they find the hooker yeah yeah
yeah that's sydney pollock um but yeah
he directed a bunch of movies too but
yeah he's he's the manager as well
yeah they kind of did and louis just
pointed out uh too that's like the 70s
was the golden age of political
thrillers uh this one the parallax view
that was another good one all the
president's men yeah it's a really good
one yeah [ __ ] what was that other one
[ __ ] uh capricorn one i want to go
back and see that but i haven't seen
that one since i was a kid when they
were faking the moon landing
yeah
that's where everybody got the idea
about stanley kubrick
and [ __ ] like that yeah but yeah and i
forgot like faye dunaway is in this
uh max von cider
max i love backspin and it's it's and
it's a dino de laurentiis flick and and
it's like
classy flicks it's like it's kind of
classy it's still fast-paced it's like
an action
advent well no it's more like an
adventure thriller survival movie with
spy stuff and uh it's all kind of not
hokey spy's [ __ ] you know what i mean
like you know
underwater submarines and you come out
and you're you're like go go gadget yeah
yeah
it was it's like what it would really be
like it is based very much in real
operations although kind of outdated by
today's standards and might have been
outdated by the the standards here and
some of it
this is like uh
kind of like oss level type stuff you
know like it's what was known about from
the 50s tricks but they were probably
doing a lot of this they were using it
wasn't really cia agents that were doing
a lot of the bad [ __ ] it was
contractors
they could recall were freelancers they
had those guys that were just assassins
but they all had backgrounds they they
pull up their backgrounds or they showed
you because they had computer systems
70s computers they'd show the dude i
don't want to spoil it you know they'd
show dudes that were involved in some
[ __ ]
[ __ ] that went down and you go oh okay
he was a gunnery sergeant served in the
honduras and korea and all these other
kind of like hot spots that were around
during the 60s and 70s so
dude might have looked like a damn
mailman but that's not what he was you
know what i mean there's all kinds of
cool [ __ ] in it you know it's trickery
and [ __ ]
um
and uh robert redford's trying to
survive and he
he has all these tricks he's picked up
from reading spy books that he's using
them well yeah cause that's like his job
he's not
he's not trained as a field uh agent he
can't even really shoot so i mean he
well he kind of he was like in the he
was in the service so they so he does
have some like experience he's not
completely green
with rifles right but they never like
really trained him right but in some
ways and i kind of like that max von
saido kind of brings this up john
houseman is in this too actually not in
a lot but in a couple of scenes but they
kind of bring this up that maybe his
inexperience with field work makes him
harder to find because he's more uh
unpredictable yeah he doesn't really
know he's doing he's lost he doesn't
well and he only knows what he's doing
because he's read like a [ __ ] ton of spy
novels because that's his job but his
job is to read spy novels and newspapers
and magazines and [ __ ] like that from
around the world to
kind of like pick up cool tips or to see
if anybody's like on to their [ __ ] like
if there's any kind of like coded
whatever they have to like feed
everything into computers that's kind of
what their whole job is yeah so the fact
that he spends all day every day reading
spy novels
um
makes it like he knows how to do all
this [ __ ] so like i said in some ways
that kind of i don't know i really like
that kind of like
bookworm kind of like uses all his like
knowledge that you think is like useless
because he just sits around reading
books all the time but yeah he's like no
man i know how to like you know trace
phone calls and like he knows how to do
all kind of crazy [ __ ] yeah and he
didn't take any of this [ __ ] seriously
he didn't take security protocols
seriously he used whatever door he
wanted to broke all kinds of rules and
[ __ ]
he didn't really consider himself to be
like a spy or anything he didn't give a
[ __ ] well that's why the whole thing
that's why it was kind of like such a
shock at the beginning because this
small office
that was you know even though it's like
a covert cia office and it's you know
called the american literary historical
society or whatever um and there's just
like you know however many people were
working there like seven or eight people
but they they weren't field agents that
was just their whole job was they just
sat there and read and they analyzed
like all these novels and all this stuff
and that so they didn't really think
anybody would do anything that anybody
would do anything to them because why
would you yeah it just kind of happened
that he sent some kind of memo that had
some kind of info in it that maybe he
kind of like clued on that maybe he was
clued on to something that he didn't
know he was clued on to
and so somebody thought well maybe we
need to like do something about that
situation
but
it's so so i really like the way that
turned out but like i said everybody in
the office it wasn't just him he was the
most egregious offender but everyone in
the office was just pretty much like
yeah whatever even though technically
you're supposed to like get buzzed in
and technically you're not supposed to
use the back door he goes out to get
everyone sandwiches yeah and he's just
like oh man it's raining i'm going out
the back door and the guy's like hey
you're not supposed to do that and she's
like oh he always does that yeah
well there's a lot i liked about this
movie of the [ __ ] score it's a really
good 70s [ __ ]
uh uh kind of like oh
did it [ __ ] did we lose it it looks like
we lost a little bit we lost it it'll be
back in a minute okay
okay we should be back
dropped a few frames one of the things i
really liked about it was it had a
really good 70s score it was uh kind of
like it was jazz but with kind of like
uh a 70s disco [ __ ] vibe to it and it
it kind of felt like uh the jazz from
blade rudder and there's detective [ __ ]
going on so it kind of has a
blade runner feel to it but not really a
look
um i thought i really liked the score
also i liked that it had action in it
but it wasn't over the top unrealistic
action when somebody did some [ __ ] it
looked like it really happened and it's
kind of a more accurate depiction of say
like
what would it be like to just eat
somebody up with a suppressed mac 10 at
close range you know they show that kind
of [ __ ]
um
pretty cool weapons that kind of come
out that sometimes it's kind of
vague what it was what but i i think i
know what most of the stuff was there
there's an uh you can go online and go
you know like the guns of and then put
the movie there and there's a database
we'll show you exactly what guns were
used and some this max von sydow uses
some [ __ ]
and it's dark so you can't see all of it
and i think i think it might have been a
mauser 98
broom handle
um
modified to be a sniper carbine he's
using it in downtown
downtown [ __ ] new york it's pretty
neat had a scope on it i think that's
what it was because that pistol kind of
had artillery models with longer barrels
and it had a butt stock that came off of
it and you could put the gun ins you
could put the pistol inside the
buttstock and it'd be small he had it he
turned it into a sniper rifle must have
been what it was but didn't show it too
clearly it was neat gotta go back and
look at it
um
yeah just a cool flick man really cool
up there with the james bond movie
with the a little bit more of a realism
i think yeah it's not totally realistic
but
better realistic i mean for a movie yeah
it's pretty grounded in reality yeah
it's pretty like down to earth yeah it
doesn't have
you know it doesn't have like spies
being like super everybody's like you
know a kung fu master and
a master of every single weapon and can
jump off bridges and not get hurt yeah
they like that you look regular they
look yeah they just look regular they
look like regular [ __ ] losers
sometimes they just look like closers
[ __ ] but they're doing because they're
designed to be
camouflaged you'd never notice them you
know that's the idea well yeah and like
i said kind of the whole premise of the
movie is that this guy is just like a
schlub
like working in some low-level cia
office who just happened to come across
some information he probably wasn't
supposed to have and then suddenly gets
embroiled in this [ __ ] that he's not
really
trained for but then like he uses
you know this kind of like odd oddball
like information that he has to sort of
like evade his you know pursuers yeah
and he was pissed that he was evidently
thinking about leaving the job because
he he got sick of it because he couldn't
tell anybody what he did yeah and it was
bothering him and he had a cute
girlfriend in there
a little chinese woman who was another
agent
and
they killed her ass
they ate her up
and she took it like a champ though it
was just it's pretty good that's just
the very beginning of the movie there's
a lot about it i don't know yeah that's
not really a spoiled because a spoiler
because that happens in like the first
year yeah
and um
but when he comes back from lunch man
everybody's dead and he thinks they're
still in there that's kind of where the
movie starts and he spends the rest of
the movie trying to figure out
who who killed all his friends and why
but he realized he couldn't really trust
anybody
it's a good movie
and faye dunaway gets into this i think
honestly i think this part of it is this
is a good part of the movie but i think
it's like the least realistic in the
sense that
basically what he does he's hiding out
like he said he figures like somebody's
out to kill me obviously as as you would
and so he's kind of like trying to hide
out
and he's in this shop
like he ducks into the shop where
they're selling like uh
ski [ __ ] or like sporting goods or
something like that
and uh he happens to like see faye
dunaway like picking something up and he
overhears her name
so when he goes out to the sidewalk he
basically takes her hostage and jacks
her car yeah he just abducts her he just
like kidnaps her right and so over the
course of it's only like a day or two
yeah um basically and he and he like
ties her up in the apartment so she
doesn't go anywhere yeah well he didn't
have a choice i know but it's like but i
the what was unrealistic i thought was
that she was just like after a day or
two she's like okay i love you now it's
you know what i mean well you don't know
if that happened a lot in the 70s though
yeah and also she's she they would let
you know that she was a weirdo
she was a weirdo by 70 standards
and um she was like an artistic type and
she was kind of like proto-goth into
real sad pictures and [ __ ] and you also
don't know and he didn't know whether or
not she was tr he was she was trying to
trick him
yeah so there was that element too you
don't know how honest and she had a
boyfriend who uh
was a dick i mean you only heard one
phone conversation with him but i was
kind of like wow that guy sounds like a
really great had a bit of a bdsm kind of
a fetish
did you notice that yeah i kind of like
i thought that maybe that's where they
were going she was tying her up with
stuff and she was
he just well then there was one thing
too where did he say you haven't asked
me to untie your hands yeah yeah so yeah
so i kind of feel like i don't know if
they could come out and necessarily say
that like at times may have not have
[ __ ] allowed maybe some of that [ __ ]
or maybe they just didn't want it to be
overt yeah it's difficult to say but
then again this is robert [ __ ]
redford
all right he's obviously a good looking
dude well i don't want to get abducted
but he's obviously anyone else for that
but he's obviously not unkempt and he's
obviously a part of something she didn't
know what to deal with
although if somebody i mean
realistically even if a good-looking
dude
kidnapped you off the street and then he
didn't hurt you necessarily but he'd
kind of like push you around and took
your car
and he's like oh hey i'm going to stay
in your apartment for a few days and you
can't leave my side oh and by the way i
work for the cia and all these people
are trying to kill me you would think
that he was insane yeah i would think
that he was insane it was also obviously
he wasn't interested in her
yeah he he would have raped her
already
but he he wasn't interested in her but
she even makes a comment about that
because he even says something like well
i haven't raped you and she said well
the night's still young
and i was like damn he was got a live
one here he was worried well all his
friends got killed yeah he was too
worried about what was going on on
television the news reports and stuff
you just got to see the movie people
like i said you wouldn't like from her
point of view you wouldn't know it was
this is just this random dude that
grabbed you off the streets now to go to
sleep
nothing is that he just wanted to go to
sleep too yeah just you know he needs a
place to sleep uh so i think she thought
that he had killed somebody and robbed
him that type of deal but he wasn't
interested in her
um
[ __ ] happened later but
i thought it was a good movie man
[ __ ] classic flick
um
and it's realistic from the point of
view of say like
what it would be to be an intelligence
so in an intelligence group
he had a military background his unit
got wiped out so he clicked into action
he was going to go in but he got scared
it did [ __ ] didn't seem right um yeah
because all this spy novels he read he's
like i should probably not trust anybody
and as it turns out most of the time he
was writing right so he
kind of goes rogue but he's doing it to
save himself
but this whole thing about abducting
people and doing the weird [ __ ] that he
did
that would be fair in the intelligence
agency because in in a way you're
fighting for the country too
you know what i mean this is uh
this is kind of like a patriotic
responsibility to find out what had
happened because
american
employees of the intelligence ages got
killed
so now he
that's that's defending people of your
unit and the primary loyalties to the
unit i like to that he did like some
dumb [ __ ]
at the beginning like at the beginning
like they they even told him when he
called in like you're supposed to do
when something bad happens he did what
he was supposed to do
but then he was kind of like i don't
really know but they told him well don't
go home obviously because somebody is
after you guys so he did actually kind
of go by his house yeah um dudes were
there and kind of saw dudes were there
but he so he did do some dumb [ __ ] but
not really like and but the fact that he
didn't really know what to do exactly he
just knew he didn't trust anybody and
that he had to go somewhere where nobody
knew where he was yeah um that's what
ended up like yeah abducting him doing
yeah him abducting people and doing
things this all would have been part of
his standing orders
in any kind of a unit that would be like
this you would have standing orders
report to your higher up protect
yourself do this and that you'd have
certain orders about who is expecting
even though like i said
like he's going through his protocol at
this particular office they seemed
really relaxed because even when he
caught when he called in
it's like he remembered his code name
which was condor but he didn't remember
any of the other people's code he's like
he's like uh [ __ ] i don't know
hummingbird nightingale whatever
well it wasn't a reality to him right
because they weren't field agents that's
what i mean somebody else's job it was
just like a [ __ ] type of job yes i
think he you know he would have had a
very basic training and a bunch of
standing orders that you'd got at the
very basic levels but he wasn't using
those and it was so rusty it took him a
while yeah it's like when you first
start working at a place and you read
the employee handbook you don't remember
like if [ __ ] really goes bad you're like
oh damn i read that like [ __ ] years
ago i don't know
that whole company as he calls it is a
bunch of dudes that are basically
criminals basically they're doing all
kinds of dirty tricks they're killing
people and
uh doing things and lying cheating
stealing and killing to get certain
things done for national security and
that that's why that shit's secret
especially back in those days that was
cold war era they did [ __ ] like that
but a lot of times not themselves they
hired other people to do it which they
showed that in this
yeah i really liked max von sydow's
character that that um that scene with
uh robert redford and max fonsito in the
elevator like in that building i really
liked that scene yeah like it was like
super tense yeah it's called wet work
and you know the intelligence agency
stop
stopped doing wet work themselves most
of the time because you need an extra
barrier or protection so they hire
somebody else that way that if that
person gets caught there's no connection
to the to the agencies so
they hire assassins
or criminals to do it people from
cartels
they used to do world war ii they had
the mafia worker for them
and now and then they late in recent in
recent times they hire cults to do it
yes
okay
louie says uh tom and jenny did you
watch the tv series condor also based on
the book it was pretty good ten episodes
if i remember correctly ten episodes all
right yeah well [ __ ] is that how like
how old is it
is that like recent
because the novel came out in 1974 yeah
i'd have to like
like i said i just did a really quick
skim of like but it seemed like i mean
the the frame story was the same yeah
but they changed a lot of stuff they
changed like the location and they
changed some various other things
um but i think this might have got
uh
an academy award nomination for best
editing it's a tight flick
it's a tight flick it's got a great
story
fast paced fast moving it's got a lot of
[ __ ] to think about 2015 or 2016. okay
yeah and that's a reset let's check it
out
um it's um it's got a fast pace
to it
um grounded in reality also has some
philosophy brought to you by maxwell
sydow is in it so and you know about how
to be above all this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah which i was like yeah that's
right
don't think about this it's just it's
just you and it's calm yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
it's just you
[Laughter]
that was a good scene that was a good
thing yeah everyone's like max monsanto
was really good in this yeah he's not
like he's not in a huge amount i guess
he's kind of like a he's a supporting
character right yes but every scene with
him is like really good yeah he kind of
steals the show he kind of does yeah oh
i think we like we lost it again i think
it's just yellow we are actually this is
probably all i have to say about it
unless you had any more to talk about
the production yeah because this seems
kind of like
man it's i know it came out a long time
ago like in 1975 but this is kind of one
of those ones that if you haven't seen
it it's probably better to like watch it
not really knowing about all the twists
and turns and stuff because it's like
way better if you don't because i saw it
a long time ago but i didn't remember
like anything that happened in it
you know what i mean louie's saying
check out um [ __ ] enemy of the state
i saw that too but that was a while back
yeah yeah that was good too and the
conversation i think i've seen that and
that was actually really good too
but yeah there's all kind of good
uh
good spy thrillers like that like i said
a lot of really good ones came out in
the 70s we're gonna check out the
marathon man even though it's not really
a spy movie it's about you know there
there's like an escaped nazis in it who
they're kind of like spies that's pretty
good
yeah i haven't seen that one in a long
time either now i'm kind of like in the
i'm in a 70s kind of movie yeah for
watching all these kind of 70s
yeah nazis nazis on the run
they called it the rat line they were
trying to get the nazis out
secretly and then they were getting in
trouble all around the world down in
argentina the united states and new york
nazis yeah dustin hoffman runs into one
yeah nazi with diamonds it's all kinds
of [ __ ] that happens
well they're not nazis anymore they're
just
escape the core criminals they're just
old dudes who are willing to kill you to
get to get to safety and [ __ ] you know
and to protect one another that reminded
me of that stephen king story apt pupil
did you read that one
no it was a novella they made a movie
out of it that actually wasn't bad
but uh yeah it was about the same it was
about basically a kid who
he goes over to like read to like the
old guy next door and finds out he's a
nazi war criminal yeah so it's like it's
yeah it's really good
uh all right so is that all we have to
say about yeah yeah cause like yeah just
recommending the film this is a good one
check it out especially if you're a fan
of uh you know the newer james bond
movies or just any kind of spy type
movies this is a good one
it's not too overly complicated it's not
real um
uh uh [ __ ]
fanciful and fantastical or anything
it's just like some [ __ ] that actually
did what could happen i like yeah like i
said i kind of like i mean i don't mind
the james bond james bond type stuff but
those are obviously fantasy uh to a
large extent um with all the flashy cars
and all that kind of like you know
that's
this one is much more like
what it would really be like if you kind
of had a low-level cia job and then
suddenly you were thrust into this kind
of like more like a mafia movie almost
kind of and then it had an ambiguous end
like you know the [ __ ] cia guys yes
but will they print it yeah will they
print it
and [ __ ] they just leave it like that
no [ __ ] answer no they won't print it
they won't print it because they in
there too
yeah
they got dirt on them they're not going
to print it
yeah yeah this is a damn good one yeah
damn good one we're gonna have to watch
the parallax view and
stuff too because i haven't seen that in
a long time either okay
and uh yeah and all the president's man
obviously that's like that's like a
classic but yeah so uh i guess that'll
do it for today thanks everybody for
dropping by uh tomorrow's wednesday so
tomorrow night we're gonna do
our regular episode at 5 p.m
we're gonna do uh this one by an
overwhelming amount of votes
uh scary scotland we're gonna be talking
about i'm doing three different cases
they're short though um we're doing the
dog suicide bridge all right and uh the
big gray man
and uh one other thing oh and like the
the haunted vaults like underneath
edinburgh okay so we're gonna be talking
about that so that should be fun be a
nice like paranormal all right type show
we haven't done one of those in a while
yeah so uh yeah so thanks everybody for
coming by have a good rest your day and
we'll see you guys tomorrow evening
bye